merci de m'accueillir parmi vous c'était
évidemment un plaisir et ça va vous
permettre à moi même de faire le point
et de prendre un petit peu de recul par
rapport à des événements nombreux qui se
sont déroulées depuis le mois de janvier
et qui ont sans doute mis en lumière un
certain nombre de fracture qui
traversent notre société et dante
l'école finalement se retrouve être la
résonance la vitrine et la façon dont
nous veillons à répondre aux difficultés
qui se présentent aujourd'hui et que je
résumerais en disant que les attentats
de janvier dernier ont eu pour effet et
on peut s'en réjouir que beaucoup de
français ont tourné leurs yeux vers
l'école en se demandant comment mieux
éduquer nos enfants pour que de telles
choses ne puisse plus jamais se
reproduire dans la foulée vous le savez
l'école s'est mobilisée notamment en
demandant à ce que dans chaque
établissement scolaire soit respecté une
minute de silence à la mémoire des
victimes
laquelle minute de silence a été dans un
certain nombre d'endroits perturbée pour
diverses raisons qui nous ont amenés
collectivement à nous interroger
évidemment à réunir la communauté
éducative comme je lé fais dans les
jours qui ont suivi et à faire en sorte
d'organiser ce qu'on a appelé la grande
mobilisation de l'école pour les valeurs
de la république
ou comment nous assurer que en plus de
transmettre des savoirs l'école
transmettent bien des valeurs aux
enfants qu'elle reçoit de ce point de
vue nous avons évidemment
d'abord veiller à ce que tous les
incidents puisse être remontée dans les
meilleures conditions possibles parce
que le premier des risques que nous
courons c'est de minimiser ou de
sous-estimer le type d'incident qui
peuvent se dérouler dans les écoles et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
renforcé nos procédures en matière de
signalement des phénomènes par exemple
de radicalisation que l'on peut
constater et la coopération entre le
ministère de l'éducation nationale et
l'ensemble des services de l'état
étaient renforcés de ce point de vue là
ce qui me permet de vous dire que au 20
mai dernier nous avons eu 1 816
signalements qui avait été transmis aux
services compétents de la police ou la
justice grâce à la vigilance des
établissements scolaires qui s'approprie
de plus en plus les outils qu'on met à
leur disposition pour faire remonter ces
cas problématiques bien sûr qui dit
suffisent suspicion pardon de
radicalisation ne dit pas radicalisation
il faut faire attention nos personnels
sont invités à alerter sur leurs doutes
mais c'est ensuite le travail de la
cellule de suivi préfectoral qui doit
établir ce qui relève ou pas de la
radicalisation donc l'éducation
nationale coopère avec les services de
justice le ministère de l'intérieur
grâce en particulier à deux outils très
efficaces qui sont le premier le système
d'information qu'on appelle le civis et
puis le deuxième les enquêtes de
victimation et de climat scolaire qui
nous permette d'objectiver les faits de
violence scolaire qui peuvent se
dérouler dans les établissements nous
avons fait évoluer ses dispositifs en
novembre dernier et désormais nous
savons que chaque soir les chefs
d'établissement transmettre de façon
systématique aux autorités compétentes
les faits problématiques qui se sont
déroulées dans leur établissement
c'est ainsi qu'on en arrive à ces
chiffres qui peuvent vous sembler
important mais en réalité c'est l'effet
d'une amélioration de notre système
statistique
la grande mobilisation pour les valeurs
de la république pour revenir à l
en refermant cette parenthèse du suivi
statistique ça a consisté à dire l'école
ne peut pas être seuls les enseignants
ne peuvent pas être seul pour répondre
aux fractures qu'on évoquait ou aux
défis qui sont posés à leurs élèves et
donc elle a consisté cette grande
mobilisation à regarder comment
s'appuyer davantage sur les acteurs qui
entoure l'école je pense aux
collectivités locales je pense aux
fédérations de parents d'élèves
je pense à tous ceux qui ont dit leur
disponibilité pour venir donner un coup
de main et c'est pour cela que nous
avons décidé d'ouvrir une réserve
citoyenne dans l'éducation nationale
pour permettre
ils sont déjà 4660 à s'y être inscrit à
des citoyens volontaires devenir
intervenir dans les écoles chacun sur
son expertise sur son expérience pour
aider à transmettre ses valeurs
c'est ainsi aussi que nous avons pris la
décision à partir de la rentrée scolaire
prochaine de développer dans les
établissements scolaires les service
civique des jeunes qui seront ils sont
5000 à la rentrée scolaire donc dépêché
dans les établissements pour accompagner
des projets des élèves des projets des
équipes pédagogiques
et là encore veiller à améliorer le
climat scolaire
je continue en vous disant que ce qu'ils
aient beaucoup ressorti de cette grande
mobilisation et de cette consultation
tous azimuts c'est l'importance du
principe de laïcité bien entendu ça ne
vous étonnera pas madame la présidente
le la laïcité qui doit au sein des
écoles protéger les élèves du
prosélytisme protéger aussi des
irruptions identitaire mais qui est une
laïcité qui a d'abord vocation à
organiser la cohabitation harmonieuse et
de ce point de vue là un certain
d'enseignants nous ont dit ne pas être
toujours armé outillés pour expliquer ce
qu'est la laïcité pour la transmettre
dans de bonnes conditions et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons décidé
de mieux les former à cette laïcité à
l'enseignement moral et civique que nous
introduisons
la rentrée prochaine de la primaire
jusqu'à jusqu'au lycée pour faire en
sorte que ces enseignants soient
davantage en mesure de répondre à des
questions qu'ils ont parfois eu du mal à
affronter pendant les incidents de
janvier et nous avons ainsi entre le
mois d'avril et le mois de mai déjà
formés 1200 formateur pendant ce
vocabulaire mais en l'occurrence des
cadres de l'éducation nationale c'est à
dire des chefs d'établissements des
inspecteurs des conseillers pédagogiques
des référents laïcité qui seront à leur
tour amené à former 300 mille
enseignants d'ici la fin de l'année 2015
pour répondre à ces défis
je parlais de l'enseignement moral et
civique c'est une nouveauté importante
qui va donc voir le jour à la rentrée
prochaine
cela se traduira concrètement sur
l'ensemble d'une scolarité d'un enfant
entre le primaire et le lycée par 300
heures d'enseignement qui lui seront
délivrées non pas sous la forme d'un
enseignement magistral théorique
descendants mais d'un enseignement qui
s'appuie bien sûr un programme puisque
ce programme a été rédigé par le conseil
supérieur des programmes et donc que
nous l'avons adopté mais qui s'organise
essentiellement autour de débats car ce
qu'il est apparu c'est que c'est sous
surtout l'esprit critique des élèves
qu'il faut davantage développée pour
ensuite lui leur transmettre ces valeurs
républicaines dont nous parlons est donc
c'est au tour du débat autour de la
capacité à trier l'information a utilisé
pour ce faire les outils numériques dont
on sait que souvent loonois la formation
les élèves concernés que cet
enseignement moral et civique
s'organisera l'année prochaine il sera
lui même un élément d'un tous que nous
avons qualifié de parcours citoyen qui
signifie que chaque établissement est
invité dans son projet d'établissement a
organisé pour les élèves
et bien cette possibilité au delà de cet
enseignement moral et civique de
participer à la vie démocratique
citoyenne de l'établissement de prendre
des responsabilités de développer les
relations partenariales avec les
associations qui entoure l'établissement
pour faire en sorte que les élèves
fassent l'expérience le plus tôt
possible de la citoyenneté et nous
réfléchissons en ce moment même à la
façon dont cela peut être valorisée dans
l'évaluation des élèves une deuxième
chose qui nous est apparu au delà de la
laïcité c'est le faible niveau d'un
certain nombre d'enfants d'élèves dans
l'expression en français tout simplement
d'où la priorité que nous avons décidé
d'accorder à l'enseignement de la langue
française
parce que il est vrai qu'il est
particulièrement difficile de débattre
ou de défendre ses idées lorsqu'on ne
maîtrise pas les mots c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous le verrez dans les
nouveaux programmes que nous préparons
actuellement et en particulier
d'ailleurs dans ceux qui ont déjà été
adoptées pour l'école maternelle et qui
entreront en vigueur à la rentrée
prochaine
la maîtrise du langage est devenu une
priorité avec y compris prévu de façon
inédite une évaluation en classe de ce2
dès le premier trimestre qui permettra
de vérifier les acquis des élèves pour
ensuite adapter nos enseignements
je continuerai d'ailleurs en faisant une
allusion très rapide j'ai compris qu'il
ne fallait pas trop s'y attarder mais à
la réforme du collège à moi j'ai le
droit d'accord d'accord mais en redisant
ici que que l'objectif de la réforme du
collège c'est bien évidemment de
garantir l'acquisition des fondamentaux
au sein desquels le français et que
l'accompagnement personnalisé en
particulier le développement du travail
en petits groupes
la refonte des programmes pour mettre
l'essentiel au coeur de ce qu'on apprend
et de ce qu'on veille à évaluer et bien
ça a vocation à renforcer cette maîtrise
du français et donc de la capacité à
développer un esprit critique à débattre
bref un devenir aussi citoyen en passant
par l'école voilà ce que je pouvais vous
dire en quelques mots je me réserve pour
vos questions mais je terminerais juste
en vous disant que cette grande
mobilisation
de l'éducation nationale autour de la
transmission des valeurs républicaines
elle a eu lieu pendant donc quatre mois
en fin du mois de janvier jusqu'à
récemment puisque nous l'avons clôturé
c'était il ya quinze jours et cette
grande mobilisation elle a dépassé nos
espérances puisque partout sur le
territoire c'est cinquante mille
personnes qui ont été amenés à
s'exprimer en disant clairement à la
fois leurs attentes considérables à
l'égard de l'école sur ce sujet et en
même temps leur disponibilité je pense
que s'il ya bien une nouveauté un
peut-être un nouveau chemin à prendre
pour l'école c'est celui de l'ouverture
plus grande à ceux qui en effet qu'il
s'agisse des parents d'élèves qu'il
s'agisse des associations qu'il s'agisse
parfois des entreprises aussi se disent
prêts à venir développer chez les élèves
à la fois la motivation mais aussi la
persévérance et puis le la compréhension
d'un certain nombre de valeurs qui
parfois leur paraissent trop théorique
en particulier lorsqu'ils ne sont pas
amenés à les vivre même voilà merci
beaucoup madame la ministre pour ces
propos qui vont dans le sens je crois de
ce qu'ils seront nos préconisations et
excusez-moi si sur le collège j'ai été
un petit peu directive c'est simplement
pour qu'on ne parle pas du latin de la
langue vivante 2 de la langue vivante
des langues régionales mais bien sûr que
la langue française est une part
importante de notre commission denquête
je vais donc laisser la parole à notre
rapporteur je vous remercie
merci présidente merci madame la
ministre lors accepter cette audition de
commission denquête et je tiens à
remercier tous les sénateurs présents
parce que je crois que c'est important
de faire honneur au ministre de la
république
même si parfois nous sommes pas d'accord
nous aurons le droit quand même de
respecter les uns et les autres est
aujourd'hui la présidente l'a bien dit
ça sera pas simplement sur la réforme du
collège même si que peut-être que les
questions peuvent être transverses
mais en tout cas ce moment aura lieu
demain donc merci vous prêter à cet
exercice
donc j'ai plusieurs questions
j'essaierai de ne pas tout les poser
pour laisser à mes collègues
l'opportunité de le faire aussi mais il
ya un à certaines dont je me dois de
d'être le transmetteur la première
question c'est par un communiqué de
presse en date du 14 janvier vous avez
annoncé vous l'aviez tout à l'heure
avoir pris connaissance de 200 incidents
liés à la minute de silence et dit qu'il
m'avait un peu plus nous des comptes sur
le fondement des documents transmis par
le ministère comme par les différents
rectorats fonds it had any d'un chiffre
bien supérieur
avez vous eu connaissance de ces
incidents faut-il intégrer la dimension
ati républicaine de certains incidents
dans les enquêtes sur le climat scolaire
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
question a trait aux enseignants chefs
d'établissements qui ont parfois le
sentiment d'être peu soutenus par leur
hiérarchie en matière de discipline et
d'atteinte aux valeurs républicaines
comment comptez-vous y remédier ensuite
dans troisième question pour de nos
auditions quelques insuffisances de
l'éducation civique juridique et sociale
nous ont été signifiées le futur
enseignement morale civique devait y
remédier je déplore l'absence au sein
des programmes de m6 des concepts de
nation de patrie qui résulte d'un choix
idéologique délibéré du conseil
supérieur des programmes qui ne les
considère pas assez inclusif
qu'en pensez vous une semaine après
l'hommage solennel qui a pu avoir lieu
au niveau des grandes des quatre grandes
figures de la résistance comptez-vous
rétablir ces concepts enfin en matière
de recrutement des personnes de leur
recrutement des personnels de
l'éducation nationale comment pouvez
vous intégrer l'impératif de l'adhésion
et de la capacité à faire adhérer ou à
faire partager les valeurs de la
république pourquoi ne pas restauré une
preuve spécifique du capes qui existait
auparavant agir en fonctionnaire éthique
et responsable pour certains nous sommes
allés dans les esprits et dans les
esprits il ya une problématique un peu
compliqué parce qu'il ya une
clarification des exigences en matière
de laïcité qui doit être souligné
en effet les étudiants et main m2 b qui
sont ce qu'on appelle reçus collés ne
sont pas astreints au respect de la
laïcité et des jeunes filles peuvent
ainsi fortement porté par don librement
le voile au cours de leur scolarité ce
qui n'est pas sans poser problème à la
différence de leurs consignes disciples
qui ont eu un concours qui sont élèves
fonctionnaires et qui n'ont pas le droit
comment garantir une formation adéquate
des enseignants à la transmission de la
valeur des valeurs de la république
ainsi que le respect de celle-ci au
cours de la formation initiale puis
peut-être quelles pourraient être les
traductions concrètes d'une orientation
de rétablissement de l'autorité des
maîtres et comment remettre du rituel
est de la solennité dans la scolarité
afin de donner du sens merci
alors ça fait beaucoup de questions bien
sûr donc madame la mise vous pouvez y
répondre bien sûr dans l'ordre dans le
désordre et de la façon qui vous
intéresse puisque dans votre propos
liminaire il y avait déjà des points que
vous avez traité
bon d'abord sur les incidents donc lié à
la minute de silence je voudrais être
sûr de m'être fait bien comprendre
pardon au moment donc de cette minute de
silence ce sont environ 200 incidents
qui nous ont été remontés jeu convient
aisément que on a connaissance que des
incidents qui nous sont remontés donc je
ne suis pas là pour
vous a sonné avec force qu'il y en a eu
deux sens sans doute qu'il y en a
utilisé davantage en tout cas ce dont je
suis sûr c'est que nous avons passé des
instructions très claires pour que rien
ne soit minimisée sous-estimé ou non non
signalée donc je crois que 207 à peu
près raisonnable comme chiffres ce dont
je vous parlais moi tout à l'heure c'est
des signalements de radicalisation qui
sont encore quelque chose d'autre qui
est lié savez aux tentations de djihad
avec une malheureusement par un certain
nombre de jeunes et pour lequel nous
avons formé à dresser un livret aux
équipes plus enseignantes et aux chefs
d'établissement sur la façon dont on
peut identifier des signaux de
radicalisation et donc c'est ce travail
là qui nous donne le résultat que
j'évoquais des 816 signalement sur la
question dont on peut donc intégrer la
dimension anti républicaine de certains
incidents
de fait quand on parle de signaler la
radicalisation c'est bien ça que ça
recouvre donc comme je vous le disais
depuis le mois de novembre nous avons
fait évoluer nos dispositif de
signalement concrètement comment ça se
passe pour vous les ayez en tête donc
chaque jour
le chef d'établissement va faire
remonter à l'inspecteur d'académie
les incidents qui se sont déroulés dans
la journée le quai l'inspecteur
d'académie transmet à l'académie qui
ensuite elle transmet au ministère les
faits qui lui paraissent les plus graves
donc il faut bien avoir conscience bien
sûr qu'il ya des faits qui parce que
considéré comme un suffisamment grave ne
nous arrive pas mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui je crois que le message est
clair
est ce qu'il y a une réticence à
signaler au sein des établissements
scolaires oui ça peut exister évidemment
par peur de voir son établissement mal
jugé par ses supérieurs ou ou parfois
par manque d'accompagnement tout
simplement des personnels et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons voulu
notamment au lendemain des incidents
liés à la minute de silence réagir en
dépêchant des cadres aguerris
c'est à dire notamment des référents
laïcité
ou des inspecteurs dans les
établissements où il y avait eu ce type
d'incident pour reprendre la discussion
avec les élèves et ne pas laisser
s'installer le silence après donc bien
sûr que la formation que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure sur les questions de laïcité
sert aussi par ailleurs à aguerrir
davantage les enseignants et à passer le
message qu'il vaut mieux signaler les
incidents plutôt que les passer sous
silence
un dernier mot pour vous dire que dans
la réforme du collège il est prévu
quelque chose qui est passée un peu
inaperçue mais qui est très important
qui est la généralisation de ce qu'on
appelle les enquêtes locales de climat
scolaire qui ont vocation régulièrement
dans chaque établissement à prendre le
pouls la température de la façon dont tu
es les équipes enseignantes et les
élèves vivent leur climat scolaire ce
qui nous permettra d'avancer sur des
questions comme le harcèlement bien sûr
où les violences scolaires mais qui nous
permettra aussi de répondre à ces
questions de d'incidents antirépublicain
beaucoup d'enseignants et chefs
d'établissement ont fait part de leur
sentiment d'être peu soutenue en matière
de gayrard en matière de discipline par
nos wii ça rejoint ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est à dire que c'est une
question de messages et de signal qui
est passé et je crois que le premier
ministre moi même avons été très clairs
au lendemain des incidents janvier sur
l'enseignement moral et civique
il est bien question de nation
vraiment le concept de nation apparaît
dans les programmes d'enseignement moral
et civique tels qu'ils ont été préparés
le sens républicain de la nation fait
partie des objets d'enseignement et
parmi les jo des objets d'enseignement
on peut aussi citer le drapeau national
l'hymne national la fête nationale ou
encore la défense nationale donc on est
bien d'accord que c'est ces programmes
ont bien vocation à transmettre en
certain nombre de savoir de
connaissances et de valeurs aux élèves
pardon je passe d'une page à une autre
ah oui pardon oui en matière de
recrutement des personnels de
l'éducation nationale comment on intègre
l'impératif de la capacité à faire
partager les valeurs de la république ça
je l' ai absolument en tête c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai écrit à
l'ensemble des présidents de jurys des
concours de l'enseignement pour leur
demander de veiller à ce que les
thématiques de la laïcité et de la
citoyenneté trouvent leur place dans les
épreuves qu'ils font passer aux
candidats ensuite j'ai répondu oui
comment garantir une formation adéquate
des enseignants la transmission des
valeurs de la république
c'est un travail qui est en cours avec
les sp pour les ans il part dans les
écoles supérieures du professeur de
l'éducation pour votre information je
les réunis
joe réunit tous les directeurs des sp
dans quelques semaines pour faire en
sorte qu' il puisse y avoir une
harmonisation de leur tronc commun
puisque la difficulté à laquelle on peut
être confrontés c'est que par la loi qui
les a créés
on a réclamé beaucoup et les sp en leur
demandant de traiter beaucoup de sujets
et
de fait on a aujourd'hui une
hétérogénéité d'un territoire à l'autre
ou certaines vont peut-être plus insisté
sur tel ou tel sujet et cette question
de la capacité à transmettre les valeurs
républicaines nous avons décidé qu'il
fallait qu'elle fasse partie du tronc
commun de toutes les espèces et donc
nous harmonisons leurs contenus dans
quelques semaines ensemble voilà et puis
peut-être pour répondre sur l'obligation
de laïcité ou neutralité qui qui
s'impose ou pas aux fonctionnaires
stagiaires dans les sp bien sûr les
fonctionnaires stagiaires sont tenus de
respecter la neutralité qui doit être
celle des fonctionnaires dont il est
attendu d'elle sauf pardon sauf et alors
il faut prendre le micro et c'est sinon
ça peut pas fonctionner de lui souffler
reçu collégiens peuvent intervenir
justement qui n'ont pas cette obligation
de ne pas être voilées ils peuvent
l'être dans ce qu'ils ratent le concours
de la fonction publique et qui sont
reçus collés qui ne sont pas obligés
d'être en neutralité comme les autres
étudiants nous parler de ceux qui ne
sont pas de fait encore fonctionnaire
oui ceux qui sont en hausse et parce que
le concours se situe bien sûr en l3
c'est bien ça le sujet sauf à le changer
d'année 1 ce qui peut être une question
qu'on peut se poser
mais aujourd'hui c'est vrai que tant
qu'on n'est pas en master nef on n'est
pas fonctionnaire donc on n'est pas
soumis aux mêmes obligations de
neutralité
en fait le sujet c'est que on est dans
cette situation dans la même situation
que tous les étudiants à la l'université
et vous savez que le non port du voile
ne s'impose pas aux étudiants à
l'université
alors merci beaucoup peut-être la
dernière question vous avez vu madame la
ministre sur l'autorité des maîtres
c'est pas magique mais elle a été posée
si si pardon c'est une question
importante la question des rites vous
souvenez qu'elle avait beaucoup fait
partie du débat en janvier nous avons
décidé d'y répondre en demandant donc à
chaque établissement dans son projet
d'établissement
de prendre une date de célébration de
cérémonies commémoratives et d'y faire
travailler donc leurs élèves
d'ailleurs autour d'un projet qui y
compris comprendra la visite par exemple
d'un sites mémoriels pour faire en sorte
qu' on puisse avoir un message un
discours un projet clair qu'ils soient
conduits et autour de cela bien sûr les
rites républicains la marseillaise tout
ce qui accompagne mais avec une
explication pédagogique qu'ils soient
apportées et donc les établissements
sont en train de travailler sur ces
projets qui nous permettent finalement
de répondre aussi bien la question de la
transmission des valeurs républicaines
que à celle de la transmission de la
mémoire
coudonc si vous voulez j'ai je vais
faire des séries de questions donc 3 3
etc
pour madame la ministre puisse les noter
et répondre de façon donc le gros
groupes et mais en même temps que tout
le monde puisse avoir la parole donc la
première question que j'ai c'est
monsieur manier bien merci madame la
présidente même le ministre chers
collègues
moi je suis d'abord très satisfait de
votre audition et d'avoir entendu les
quelques mises au point que vous avez pu
faire sur ce qui a été fait au delà des
incidents qui ont pu être relevés après
les assassinats du mois de janvier
puisque la problématique si elle a été
accentuée après ces malheureuses
affronta existait déjà auparavant et
vous avez indiqué que sur le traitement
à lèvres avait été prévu et avait été
ensuite appuyé on est
accélérée par la suite en tout cas moi
je voudrais aujourd'hui rappelé la
position de notre groupe socialiste dans
cette mission
sans cette commission denquête les qui
est là même d'ailleurs que celle de nos
camarades dans la commission des lois
qui eux aussi s'était préoccupé en
disant que bien on ne voyait pas
pourquoi une commission denquête pour
ces questions là puisque et il n'y avait
pas notre notre avis l'utilité de faire
prêter serment d'avoir toute cette
solennité autour des différentes
auditions qui ont pu être menées ici et
qui parfois ont d'ailleurs nous
entraîner sur des terrains assez assez
glissant est assez désagréable pour ce
qui nous concerne nous pensons que
l'école a besoin d'apaisement que les
enseignants ont certes besoin de
formation et je crois que les écoles
supérieures des professeurs à
l'éducation ont pris en compte ce besoin
de formation bien mieux qu'il ne l'a été
dans les dix dernières années grâce à la
réforme qui a été fait on de juillet
2013 sur la fondation de l'école et
enfin effectivement les programmes ont
besoin de rénovations et y compris
d'intégrer des matières comme
d'enseignement moral et civique
une manière beaucoup plus précise qu'il
ne le faisait jusqu'à maintenant alors
bon je ne reviendrai pas sur les
quelques intervenants qui nous ont
parfois fait frémir y compris certains
philosophes d'autres nous ont fait
plaisir
philosophe aussi je visais monsieur
bédard par exemple nous avons entendu
avec beaucoup de passion dans cette dans
cette salle il ya peu de temps
moi je suis un peu inquiet par les
diatribes parfois à peine voilée de
l'autre rapporteur qui parfois font des
diatribes sévère contre le pédagogisme
c'est pas cher collègue si vous êtes
laissés entraîner le pédagogisme en fait
la pédagogie ça existe et pédagogie sme
c'est une dérive mais je crois que dans
l'école aujourd'hui les enseignants ils
ont déjà assez à faire de la pédagogie
et jour pour accueillir beaucoup de se
blesser pédagogistes que vous
fonctionnez vous nous dit souvent qu'il
ya une baisse de niveau
quand on met en cause d'excellence et
que l'école ne peut éduquer ce n'est pas
son rôle premier est qu elle doit
d'abord instruire non mais c'est ce que
vous avez
mon cher collègue et je n'ai relevé moi
je suis venu kendra de débat
d'orientation elle a posé la question
mais je pense quand même il faut planter
le décor parce que monsieur grosperrin
et le plante le décor souvent mais moi
je voudrais le planter alors et je
viendrai je ne reviendrai pas là dessus
mais pour nous il ya eu un certain
nombre de décès le langage et qui
pourrait laisser penser que on met un
peu l'école à feu et à sang après ses
graves événements du mois de janvier et
qu'on en a profité parfois pour essayer
de faire sinon le procès au moins la
mise en cause de l'institution scolaire
certainement des enseignants puisque je
vous le faire et observer les syndicats
s'inquiètent aussi parfois de toutes ces
observations qui sont faites sur leur
travail
et pourtant comme la vie ici monsieur
léonais qui est directeur central
adjoint de la sécurité publique camp
lorsqu'il a été auditionné il n'y avait
pas autant d'incidents que ce qu'on
aurait bien voulu nous faire croire et
je crois que cette commission denquête
elle avait été faite essentiellement
pour démontrer parce que le ministère la
réponse du ministère ne suffisait pas
qu'il y avait beaucoup plus d'incidents
que ce qu'on avait pu faire remonter or
aujourd'hui eh bien je crois que tout le
monde est à peu près d'accord pour dire
qu'il n'y a pas lieu de faire tout c'est
tout c'est tous ces débats même s'ils
sont intéressants parfois puisque les
auditions sont toujours intéressantes
mais toujours de mettre autant de
solennité et de faire prêter serment
pour dire des choses tout à fait simple
qui effectivement que nous connaissons
bien et que nous rencontrons lorsque
nous allons dans les écoles alors
mesdames ministre moi je suis content
vous ayez pu rassurer je l'espère notre
reporter pour ce qui nous concerne donc
nous ne cautionnons pas les mises en
cause des enseignants de l'école
nous nous associons pas un certain
nombre de choses qui ont été dites lors
de ses auditions lors de ses
commentaires et nous prendrons notre nos
dispositions lorsque ce rapport sera
remis nous attendons avec beaucoup
d'impatience de connaître le contenu qui
sera d vous et nous l'espérons bien qui
sera dévoilée bientôt devant cette
commission
pouvez-vous aujourd'hui madame la
ministre nous préciser
je crois vous l'avez déjà répondu à
beaucoup de ces questions mais comment
nous pouvons aujourd'hui montrer aux
élèves aux parents d'élèves
comment pouvant s que montrer que
l'école est vraiment a besoin d' dans le
climat serein et qu'il faut laisser à la
porte de l'école aujourd'hui toutes les
questions qui sont d'ordre cultuel et
laïcité effectivement s'impose
malheureusement c'est une chose que l'on
dit souvent mais il faut que cela rentre
vraiment dans les faits que l'école soit
vraiment inspiré et plein de sept
valeurs de laïcité enfin comment dans la
formation des enseignants pouvons nous
affirmer et décidé encore mieux
justement une laïcité tout à fait strict
mais toujours gardé un accueil
bienveillant de nos élèves qu'ils soient
collégiens qu'ils soient lycéens ou même
qu'ils soient étudiants sur le pourra
porter je remercie merci donc la
deuxième question c'est monsieur carle
qui va l'imposer dans par respect pour
le temps imparti à la ministre weil et
de cours je vous remercie
merci ma président entouré de deux
questions madame la ministre la première
là paraît simple mais la réponse peut
être un peu moins c'est où commence et
où s'arrête l'école et donc où se
commence et où s'arrête où s'appliquent
les règles qui concerne l'école pourquoi
je vous pose cette question parce que
les enseignants que nous avons
rencontrés nous ont fait pas
effectivement des difficultés qu'ils ont
face à des signes d'un ostentatoire qui
importe atteinte à la laïcité et se
sentent et je peux confirmer ce qu'a dit
le rapporteur pas suffisamment soutenus
par leur hiérarchie
mais où ils ont des difficultés c'est à
l'extérieur des murs qu'en est il donc d
accompagnement pour les sorties
scolaires ou les accompagnements pour
les activités culturelles et sportives
quid des conseils de classe et là ils
nous ont dit qu'ils voulaient de la
clarté
deuxième question vous l'avez dit
l'école c'est une caisse de résonance de
la société des soubresauts de la société
qu'elle a sa responsabilité mais elle
n'est pas seule responsable il ya la
famille 1 et il ya aussi j'allais dire
l'environnement
de l'école or on met des corps les
sommes considérables dans chacune de ces
politiques
l'école votre budget 60 milliards je
crois la politique de la ville c'est
plus de 40 milliards
la famille c'est aussi une somme
considérable il semblerait qu il n'ya
pas j'allais dire suffisamment
d'efficacité et un manque de cohérence
d'entre ces politiques est ce qu'il
faudrait pas avoir une vision
transversale pour que ces politiques et
plus de synergie et la troisième
question de cette première série madame
blanc des merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre et deux questions sur
votre politique et de questions plutôt
sur votre opinion sur la réunion qui va
avoir lieu les sp dont je me réjouis
qu'elle flèche les valeurs de la
république comme un élément
indispensable du tronc commun
je vous demande si vous avez prévu
d'inciter les directeurs à associer des
acteurs de l'éducation populaire qui
sont quand même très féru de
l'enseignement du respect de l'autre par
l'exemple de la culture de l'engagement
associations de ces acteurs qui avaient
été prévus dans la loire au fondation de
l'école même chose sur l'évaluation dont
nous attendons les avis du ministère le
csp avait dit l'importance de mêlée
rigueur et exigence
et puis vient veillance afin que l'élève
comprennent ce qui lui manquait ce qu'il
est acquis mais surtout qu'il se sente
respecté je pense au secrétaire général
de l'enseignement catholique qui nous
disait écrire copine nul c'est pas la
dignité de l'élève c'est pas les valeurs
de la république
quoi donc voilà est-ce qu'il va y avoir
des indications là dessus deux choses
que nous avons entendu en suggestion et
sur laquelle je vous consulte
n'y aurait-il pas pertinence d'une
charte d'entrée en profession un peu à
la manière du serment d'hippocrate pour
les médecins ou les enseignants
déclarait qu'il s'engage à faire valoir
elle est telle chose ça me semble
important et un détail particulier notre
république aujourd'hui tout le monde est
d'accord sur la laïcité les valeurs de
la république mais il ya quand même
encore le concordat je me garderai bien
ne m'y attaquer ce n'est pas le lieu
simplement dans les départements du
concordat il y ait des horaires
d'enseignement religieux dont l'islam au
passage est d'ailleurs prohibées ce qui
pose un petit problème mais ces horaires
ne sont ils pas aujourd'hui à gommer au
profil de le mc ou est-ce que ça va être
compatibles merci madame la ministre si
vous voulez bien répondre merci d'abord
pour commencer par monsieur manier que
je remercie cette question du climat
scolaire en effet de la façon dont on
s'assure que l'école soit un lieu
sanctuarisé dans lequel règne la laïcité
c'est à dire qu'on transforme bien
l'enfant en élèves qu'on lui demande de
laisser à la porte de l'école
ces attributs confessionnelles c'est une
question absolument majeur parce qu'on
voit bien que de là découle aussi la
qualité du climat scolaire la capacité
des enfants à vivre apprendre à vivre
ensemble et c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis 2012
loin des procès qui nous sont faits
parfois nous n'avons cessé de promouvoir
la laïcité la charte de la laïcité a
posé dans tous les établissements
scolaires ça n'existait pas avant et je
peux vous le dire parce que j'étais
encore hier à nancy dans une petite
école en plein milieu d'un quartier en
zone urbaine sensible
avec cette charte qui voilà qui était au
vu et au su de tous et qui s'imposent
pas simplement aux enfants mais aussi
aux parents achètent tous les matins
quand ils déposent leurs enfants
il ya ces mots simples qui ont été
pensés pour l'être pour être compris de
tous qui désormais 10 ce qu'est la
laïcité donc je redis ici que ses patins
c'est pas un principe d'exclusion c'est
un principe de cohabitation harmonieuse
et au delà de cette charte de la laïcité
nous avons décidé dans les mesures que
nous avons adoptées au lendemain des
attentats et de cette grande
mobilisation de faire du neuf
décembre désormais la journée nationale
de la laïcité qui sera célébrée dans
tous les établissements et je crois que
c'est important à souligner parce que ça
veut dire on parlait tout à l'heure de
rite républicain
mais s'il est bien une valeur de la
république a célébré à faire connaître
et à faire aimer aux enfants c'est bien
celle de laïcité
cette journée on sera l'occasion et puis
je disais les enseignants avaient besoin
d'être formés c'est pour ça que nous
avons lancé ce grand plan de formation à
la laïcité que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
qui a déjà concerné 1200 formateur et
qui concernera donc trois cent mille
enseignants d'ici la fin de l'année
ils ont aussi besoin d'avoir ces
principes simples de laïcité comme base
de relations avec les parents et c'est
pourquoi nous avons prévu que désormais
à chaque rentrée scolaire les parents
seront invités à signer le règlement
intérieur et la charte de la laïcité
pour être bien assuré qu'on parle
d'elles mêmes choses et qu'ils
comprennent quelles sont les règles
qu'on fait respecter à leurs enfants sur
la question de monsieur carle où
commence et où ça va être l'école c'est
très juste vous avez raison ce qu'il est
apparu aussi dans la grande mobilisation
c'est que ce qui fragilise et les
discours des professeurs notamment sur
ces questions de laïcité c'est que
parfois
les adultes qui entourent les enfants ne
portent pas forcément les mêmes discours
et que du coup les enfants évidemment
sont toujours très contente de pouvoir
créer des coins entre les adultes et
donc il nous faut veiller à ce que non
seulement bien sûr les enseignants et
les parents disent la même chose ça on
l'a tous en tête d'où la nécessité de
promouvoir ce qu'on appelle la
coéducation mais aussi que les
enseignants et les éducateurs que sont
amenés à rencontrer les enfants dans le
cadre des animations périscolaires par
exemple ou des associations d'éducation
populaire disent la même chose sur ces
questions de valeurs de la république et
laïcité c'est la raison pour laquelle
s'agissant de laïcité on a décidé que
toutes les ressources pédagogiques que
nous développons pour former nos
enseignants à transmettre la laïcité
nous les mettons à disposition des
acteurs qui nous entourent je pense aux
collectivités locales par exemple pour
que les animateurs du périscolaire aussi
bénéficient de ce même accompagnement et
qu'on parle bien de la même chose sur la
base des mêmes ressources
donc on y travaille avec l'association
des maires de france dans le cadre des
plans éducatif territoriaux que l'on
construit pour les rythmes éducatif mais
je crois que c'est c'est au fond s'il ya
bien un mot qui est ressorti de toute la
consultation de ces quatre derniers mois
sur les territoires c'est décloisonner
décloisonner arrêté de fonctionner en
silo l'éducation nationale qui a ses
propres règles les services de santé
leurs propres règles et c est donc ce
sujet de laïcité en est une bonne
illustration tous les adultes doivent
parler la même langue quand on parle de
laïcité aux enfants parler la même
langue
ça veut pas dire pour faire le lien avec
votre question suivante être sourd à ce
qui peut se dire parfois et
et ne pas faire un effort de
compréhension j'en viens à la question
des accompagnatrices de sorties
scolaires
il ya moi je ne jette la pierre à
personne
un de mes prédécesseurs en l'occurrence
chatel avait fait adopter une circulaire
dans laquelle il précisé qu' il fallait
lutter contre le prosélytisme à l'école
et que lorsque des parents des mères en
l'occurrence porter le foulard et
qu'elle se proposait pour être
accompagné atterrissent scolaire il ne
fallait pas les y autoriser parce qu'on
considérait cela comme du prosélytisme
on a vu les effets que ça a eu sur le
terrain quand je dis que je ne jette la
pierre à personne c'est que je ne
reproche à personne de tenter quelque
chose mais ensuite il faut évaluer ce
qu'on fait et les effets que ça a eu sur
le terrain c'est que ça a été
terriblement contre-productif c'est à
dire que ça braquer des générations
entières d'enfants contre même le
principe de laïcité or si on croit au
principe de laïcité je crois qu'on doit
veiller avant tout à ce que les enfants
il y adhèrent parce que si on donne
l'impression de leur faire violence et
en l'occurrence le fait de refuser à
leur mère accompagner bénévolement une
sortie scolaire et donc de la
stigmatiser de la mettre de côté au
simple motif d'une tenue vestimentaire
sans même qu'elle ait fait preuve de
prosélytisme particulier et bien c'est
une façon de braquer les enfants
d'évidence et donc c'est pour cela que
en effet j'ai revu la position sur ce
sujet je voudrais très clair sur ma
position à moi je suis opposé à toute
forme de prosélytisme et donc je le dis
je les dis aux équipes enseignantes et
aux chefs d'établissements dès lors
qu'il y à du prosélytisme d'ailleurs
qu'ils soient politiques ou religieux ou
autre il faut bien évidemment s'opposer
à la venue dans l'établissement ou à
l'accompagnement par un parent
d'une sortie scolaire mais quand il n'y
a pas ce prosélytisme quand on est
simplement fasse un parent qui n'est pas
un agent du service public donc qui
n'est pas tenu par les mêmes règles de
neutralité
quand on est face à une volonté de
coopérer des parents je crois que nous
devons mais tout mettre en oeuvre pour
favoriser la coéducation favoriser le
travail partenarial de l'école avec les
parents c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai souhaité que dans ce type de
situation là les équipes fassent preuve
du discernement qu'on attend d'elle et
est favori cette coopération plutôt que
de la rejeter
de manière générale le maître mot en
matière de laïcité c'est discernement
c'est d'ailleurs une preuve de confiance
qui est faite aux équipes enseignantes
que de leur dire il ya certes des règles
qu'on définit au niveau national
uniformément mais ensuite il ya la
réalité du terrain et c'est aussi dans
dans le détail de la vie que ses équipes
savent comment se comporter par exemple
vous aurez noté que s'agissant de cette
jeune fille à la jupe longue qui dans un
établissement scolaire a vu ses parents
convoqués au motif qu' elles étaient
elles perturbé
eh bien j'ai pris la défense et le
soutien de l'équipe enseignante parce
que de fait j'ai pu constater qu' il y
avait perturbations il y avait ainsi
n'en est que comme je le disais tout à
l'heure nous demandons aux enseignants
de faire remonter les incidents de ne
pas les minimiser donc quand ils ont
lieu oui il faut convoquer les parents
oui il faut adopter des sanctions
éducatives pédagogiques et non il ne
faut pas laisser passer les provocations
mais c'est une question de discernement
et ça n'est évidemment pas au motif de
la couleur ou de la longueur de la jupe
que cette jeune fille a été prise à
partie c'est bien parce qu'elle avait un
comportement qui n'étaient pas
acceptables donc discernement et pour
que les enseignants puissent faire
preuve de ce discernement formation l'a
dit en initiale dans les sp on l'a dit
en continu comme je l'évoquais et puis
accompagnement c'est à dire pouvoir se
reposer sur des spécialistes au fond de
ces questions là et c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis 2012 nous avons
développé dans chaque académie des
référents laïcité qui là encore
n'existait pas auparavant donc des
monsieur ou madame qui sont
spécifiquement chargé d'accompagner les
équipes sur ces sujets madame blandin
sur la question de désespérer du fait
d'associer les acteurs de l'éducation
populaire
oui d'abord je voudrais vraiment insisté
sur le fait que le ministère de
l'éducation nationale soutient beaucoup
les acteurs de l'éducation populaire
enfin vous le savez évidemment vous mais
c'est pas forcément su à l'extérieur et
on le fait parce que de fait
il ya un travail efficace qui est
conduit par ces associations et nous
souhaitons en effet développer leur
implication dans les formations qui
seront délivrés par les sp sur sur le
reste on pour m'interroger sur notre
calendrier en matière d'évaluation
je redis ici que la réforme du collège
que nous avons conduite est un tout il
s'agit bien à la rentrée 2016 d'avoir à
la fois une organisation du collège des
pratiques pédagogiques qui évolue je ne
reviens pas dans le détail
un des programmes qui sont revue et
repensée pour mettre l'acquisition des
fondamentaux en leur coeur et qui sont
pensés en cohérence avec les nouvelles
pratiques pédagogiques pour dire les
choses clairement dès lors qu'on
introduit de la d'interdisciplinarité il
faut que ça se retrouve dans les
programmes par exemple et pour boucler
la boucle et que tout cela fasse un
ensemble cohérent il s'agit bien aussi
de réformer l'évaluation donc d'avoir un
nouveau diplôme du brevet qui en effet
soit à la fois exigeants clairement et
qui en même temps soit stimulant parce
que nous estimons que l'évaluation elle
est faite aussi pour encourager faire
progresser les élèves
et puis un diplôme national du brevet
qui tout simplement conforte les
évolutions que nous avons introduit
typiquement si dans notre réforme du
collège nous voulons mettre l'accent
davantage sur la maîtrise de l'oral en
plus de celle de l'écrit mettre l'accent
davantage sur la capacité des élèves à
coopérer à travailler ensemble à mener
des projets il faut que cela se traduise
ensuite parce que le brevet vient
sanctionner évalué donc c'est l'objet de
cette réforme du brevet pardon qui va
être adoptée prochainement et qui
entrera en vigueur aussi à la rentrée
2016 j'ai noté les deux derniers points
juste un mot j'ai noté la l'idée d'une
charte d'entrée en enseignement je pas
si vous l'aviez formulé comme ça mais
c'est comme ça qu'il est noté mais je
trouve l'idée est intéressante je pense
qu'elle mérite d'être creusée et puis
sur la question de l'enseignement
religieux
j'insiste sur l'enseignement laïc du
fait religieux donc j'avais indiqué
après janvier que je souhaitais le voir
renforcée dans les nouveaux programmes
puisqu'on a d'une certaine façon la
chance de voir l'ensemble des programmes
qui sont refondus donc le csp que vous
connaissez bien le conseil supérieur des
programmes a reçu cette instruction et
le travail est en cours pour faire en
sorte que cet enseignement laïque du
fait religieux soit bien présent sur les
trois monothéismes
et il ne s'agit pas là encore
d'apprendre une fois aux élèves mais de
développer leur esprit critique à
l'égard de ce qui peut s'écrire en la
matière merci voilà pour cette audition
de najat vallaud belkacem la ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui avait donc été
auditionnés au mois de juin par la
commission denquête sur le service
public de l'éducation
depuis au mois de juillet et bien cette
commission denquête a rendu son rapport
et a fait vingt propositions choc alors
parmi ces propositions on peut notamment
citer bien le rétablissement de
l'uniforme scolaire également la baisse
des allocations familiales en cas
d'absentéisme ou encore le recentrage du
programme d'histoire sur le récit
national mais aussi la création d'un
centre particulier pour accueillir les
élèves perturbateurs
tout un programme donc qui suscite le
débat et à propos duquel les sénateurs
ont d'ailleurs proposé l'organisation
prochainement d'un débat au sénat
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires